the great monitor arc and an iPad
typewriter it's episode 30 of IMG here's
the world's largest Lego tower and
here's an egg fried into a duck face you
know you're patriotic when you resort to
kittens although I prefer driving a
horse in my car oh yeah oh stop being a
poop head and now the worst eyebrows
ever connected segmented leaves and the
ultimate total face beer converse shoes
pants fart pants Shh Ludacris is
watching and so is this kitty but
where's the cat in this picture if you
can find it reward yourself with a trip
to Choate of our breweries beer Wellness
land if I was a sports team this would
be my mascot or maybe it would be a
bacon cannon that shoots sausages or
real-life hipster Ariel either way this
is what my mother dressed me in as a
child but keep it a secret okay just
like these cats and dogs are doing
[Music]
Giff brain how much dirt do you want one
shovel fall or an entire mountain this
chart shows the complete evolution of
Apple products and this image shows
candy bar cross-sections
how many can you identify no sweet tooth
grab some seafood and Saudi Arabian
officials have just greenlight plans to
build a mile-high building in Dubai if
the Empire State Building is this the
mile-high building would compare like
this oh yeah and this guy still alive
but he says he doesn't like the Beatles
on facebook.com slash Vsauce gaming you
can submit your own favorite images and
view what others have submitted for
instance Annabelle gave us a cupcake
Cookie Monster breck gave us a running
refrigerator Conner caught a vsauce fry
and lanlan asked is she cute well I
should probably point out that she is
actually a boy Ken petrus is now 18 and
was originally known as 10 Petrus but as
early as 12 she began gender
transformation treatments creepy Spider
Man be sure to subscribe to Vsauce to
win and tell your friends to subscribe
to Vsauce to dominate keep in mind there
are always going to be edible marzipan
babies but as always thanks for watching